JILLIAN: WELCOME BACK, TEXAS AND
MISSOURI ARE SUING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR SCRAPPING THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
CLAIMING THE BORDER SURGE IS
PUTTING UNPRECEDENTED BURDEN ON
STATE AND FEDERAL RESOURCES.
JOINING ME LIVE ONE OF THE KEY
PLAYERS THAT LAWSUIT TEXAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN PAXTON,
SIR, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING.
WE APPRECIATE IT?
>> GOOD MORNING.
JILLIAN: GOOD MORNING.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING TO
COME OF THIS?
WHAT ARE YOU HOPING COMES OF
THIS LAWSUIT?
>> WELL, WOULD WE THINK THIS IS
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
IMMIGRATION POLICIES THAT TRUMP
PUT IN PLACE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY WORKING VERY
WELL, PEOPLE STAY IN MEXICO
EVERYBODY FIGURED OUT
IMMIGRATION THEY COULD COME IN
AND CLAIM ASYLUM EVEN THOUGH
ONLY ABOUT 14% END UP GETTING
ASYLUM AND DISAPPEAR INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THIS POLICY WAS ACTUALLY
WORKING.
WHY JOE BIDEN DECIDED TO UNDO
SOMETHING SO SUCCESSFUL WE DON’T
KNOW.
WE BELIEVE WE WILL WIN IN COURT
AND THAT THIS POLICY WILL BE
BACK IN PLACE.
JILLIAN: WE WILL CERTAINLY
CONTINUE TO FOLLOW THAT YOU
KNOW, IN THE MEANTIME WITH EACH
DAY THAT PASSES DO YOU WONDER
THE THREAT LONG TERM HOW MUCH
GREATER THAT THREAT IS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES, NOT JUST ALONG THE
BORDER BUT THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF SPECIFICALLY
THE INFILTRATION OF DRUGS THAT
HAVE COME ACROSSED BORDER.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT AS THE
NUMBERS INCREASE, THEY WILL MOVE
OUT OF TEXAS AND THE BORDER
STATE.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE TAKING THE
BRUNT OF IT.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
HERE THAT WEREN’T HERE TWO
MONTHS AGO.
THOSE PEOPLE WILL START BEING
MOVED AROUND BECAUSE WE DON’T
HAVE ENOUGH PLACES FOR THEM TO
STATEMENT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY WE WILL START SEEING AS
TIME GOES ON THEY WILL START
SEEING THE IMPACT OF HIGHER
CRIME RATE, OF COVID, THE
TRANSMISSION OF COVID AND OTHER
DISEASES AND ISSUES WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND DRUG-SMUGGLING
THAT WE ARE SEEING.
JILL ARE YOU DISAPPOINTED THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
HAVEN’T VISITED THE BORDER YET
AND HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO THEM
ABOUT IT.
>> I HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO THEM
ABOUT IT BUT I’M EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED.
ONE OF THE MAJOR ISSUES OF OUR
TIME GIVEN THEIR POLICY CHANGES
THE IMPACT I WOULD EXPECT THEM
TO GO DOWN TO THE BORDER AND
START TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND HOW IT’S AFFECTING
TEXANS AND TALK TO PEOPLE BEING
ACTIVISTED INCLUDING THE PEOPLE
ON THE BORDER DOING THE WORK.
JULY JILL NOW, LET’S TALK ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE TODAY DEMOCRATS ARE
EXPECTED TO UNVEIL A BILL THAT
WOULD EXPAND THE SUPREME COURT
TO 13 JUSTICES.
LET’S TAKE A LISTEN TO JOE
BIDEN’S STANCE ON THIS.
HIS STANCE HAS FLIP FLOPPED A
LITTLE BIT.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> YOU WILL KNOW MY OPINION ON
COURT-PACKING WHEN THE ELECTION
IS OVER.
>> I’M NOT A FAN OF
COURT-PACKING.
>> ARE YOU OPEN TO EXPANDING THE
COURT?
>> I’M OPEN TO CONSIDERING WHAT
HAPPENS FROM THAT POINT ON.
JILLIAN: AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHAT DO YOU THINK ENDS UP
HAPPENING HERE AND HOW DANGEROUS
WOULD THIS BE?
>> WELL, IT LOOKS PURELY
POLITICAL.
I THINK MOST OF THE MEMBERS OF
THE COURT HAVE EXPRESSED
OPINIONS ON, THIS EVEN RUTH
BADER GINSBURG SAID THERE IS NO
REASON TO PACK THE COURT IT.
LOOKS POLITICAL THAT BODY IS
VIEWED AS NONPOLITICAL.
SUPPOSED TO RULE ON THE LAW NO.
REASON GIVEN WHY THEY WANT TO
DISSIPATE THE CURRENT IMPACT OF
THE COURT.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THE DIRECTION
WE ARE GOING.
I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE DON’T
CHANGE THINGS JUST FOR POLITICAL
REASONS.
RIGHT NOW, THAT’S WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE.
JILLIAN: REAL QUICK, OBVIOUSLY
IT SEEMS LIKE THE LEFT WOULD
WANT TO DO THOUGH HELP THE LEFT,
RIGHT?
DO YOU THINK ULTIMATELY IF THIS
ENDED UP HAPPENING THIS COULD
END UP HELPING REPUBLICANS WE
HAD CONGRESSMAN STEUBE ON
EARLIER SAYING LOOK THIS COULD
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE 2022 HOUSE
RACES.
>> NO DOUBT.
MAYBE ONE OF THE MAIN OF THE
MESSAGES OF THE RACES COME UP
AND COULD BACKFIRE AND THAT’S
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DO
SOMETHING NEXT STREAM.
JILLIAN: TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US AND KEEP US UPDATED ON
EVERYTHING THAT’S GOING ON IN
YOUR STATE.
I KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON AT THE
BORDER CERTAINLY IMPACTS SOME
PEOPLE DOWN THERE AND THEY WANT
TO GET SOME ANSWERS, AND I KNOW